[Music]
I never set out to upset anyone
however I was not uncomfortable with
getting off my pedestal Harry Potter
author JK Rowling is doubling back on
her anti-trans comments claiming on the
upcoming podcast The Witch Trials of JK
Rowling that her past remarks over the
last three years were misunderstood
you've ruined your legacy oh you could
have been beloved forever but you chose
to say this
and I think you could not have
misunderstood me more profoundly
the podcast is said to provide
unprecedented Candor and depth about the
controversies surrounding her from book
bans to debates on gender and sex and
will include interviews with rolling
supporters and critics journalists
historians clinicians and more and while
many Harry Potter stars including Daniel
Radcliffe Rupert Grint and Emma Watson
have spoken out against Rowling's past
anti-trans remarks it seems a new actor
is being caught up in Rowling's
controversies
Sebastian Croft two stars in Netflix's
lgbtq plus series Heart Stopper it's so
good provides the voice of the playable
character in the new Harry Potter game
Hogwarts Legacy and while the game
offers Hogwarts first ever trans
character sirona Ryan the game was hit
with some major backlash causing Croft
to tweet out I was cast in this project
over three years ago back when all Harry
Potter was to me was the magical world I
grew up with this was long before I was
aware of JK Rowling's views I believe
wholeheartedly that trans women are
women and trans men are men now he
followed up by stating I know far more
now than I did three years ago and hope
to learn far more in the next three I'm
really sorry to anyone hurt by this
announcement there is no LGB without the
team
[Laughter]